- Rita est chanceuse.
Son fils vient la chercher
pour l'amener chez le coiffeur.
Elle n'y allait plus depuis
le début de la pandémie.
À 86 ans, elle a survécu
à la vague de COVID qui
a déferlé au CHSLD Yvon-Brunet
où elle habite, grâce,
entre autres, à son fils.
RITA LEVASSEUR, 86 ans,
résidente du CHSLD Yvon-Brunet
- Il venr au travers
la clôture puis on s'envoyait
la main puis des bisous,
comme ça.
- Un baume pour son coeur
devant la mort qui rôdait.
- J'ai pas aimé ça là, t'sais.
Ça fait... Ça nous fait de quoi
au coeur d'en voir partir,
là, t'sais. Tu te dis :
Bien câline! Il sont pas
chanceuxes!
Moi, bien, j'ai été chanceuse,
merci mon Dieu!
- Seulement lors de la première
vague, 73 résidents sont morts
de la COVID.
JULIEN, médecin
- Je revois les noms,
les visages de ceux qui
sont partis puis la douleur
est presque aussi présente
qu'il y a deux ans.
- Et des images qui
ne s'effaceront jamais.
JOCELYN PELLETIER, employé
au CHSLD Yvon-Brunet
- Un matin, je suis arrivé
avait quatre corbillards
en avant de la porte.
- Pour ne pas oublier,
le 11 mars est devenu
date de commémoration
des victimes de la COVID.
Dans une lettre,
François Legault souligne que :
"Le Québec a fait ce qu'il
fallait pour sauver le plus
de vies possible", écrit-il.
Contrairement à l'an dernier,
pas de cérémonie, pas de minute
de silence, seulement
des drapeaux en berne.
- C'est un moment
qu'il ne faut pas oublier.
- C'est pourquoi des aînés
de l'arrondissement du Sud-Ouest
se sont .
Dans un contexte où Québec
assouplit les mesures
sanitaires, les changements
dans le traitement des aînésse .
- Là, on sent qu'il y
a une oreille qui s'ouvre.
J'en voudrais deux, mais qu'il y
Mais là, je veux voir
les résultats.
- De son côté, Rita sent que
l'étau de la COVID se relâche,
ce qui ouvre la porte à d'autres
beaux moments avec son fils.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada,
Montréa